[Music]
sequence
how are either one of those options a
good way to spend a summer vacation
maybe flying a rocket but building it
that would take three
summers minimum and who wants to
actually fight a mummy it's like a 98
chance you would die it might be slow
but they're also immortal and super
strong so eventually they would catch
you and bash your
skull in also this mummy is way too big
for this coffin sarcophagus
sarcophagus anyhow quit squishing tall
people our spine's already hurt
discovering something that doesn't exist
show insinuates that the duck-footed
tertuna cronoceros doesn't exist
creating nanobots or locating
frankenstein's brain
pretty sure you mean frankenstein's
monster's brain
mom phineas and ferb are making a title
sequence
sisters you know verb one of the best
times we ever had was when we built that
roller coaster
we should do it again but this time as a
musical
living in the past
though it might sound just a bit cliche
excusing your cliche by admitting it's a
cliche
um cliche i really wish this sudden
tuxedo hadn't included this sudden top
hat because the way it just hangs off of
phineas's head blade
just made me think about the
triangle-shaped skull that's underneath
i may never sleep again
this sudden cat's homage comes out of
nowhere and now i have the one-two punch
of being uncomfortable with felinius and
ferb
as well as the haunting trauma of a
darkened theater in 2019.
it's quite possible 2020 is a punishment
for the movie cats and
honestly we might deserve it somewhere
in my brain i know that the animators
are just cheaply using my own nostalgia
for these musicals against me for their
own gain but it's working i'm only human
and singing in the rain is the best
movie ever and i love it so much and
just take your sin off while i'm still
under your spell you animated bag of
choice nostalgia crack okay memory
dealers
nope you haven't stumbled into 4chan or
deviantart this is an actual shot from
the episode and honestly i really don't
have anything more to add
this song had one short verse and now
has been hay fur being on for some time
in fact for the entire some time of the
rest of the song i'm not saying it's not
catchy
i'm just saying it's lazy songing i know
this is a running gag but i refuse to
hear any other explanation for the
floating baby head other than finifer
found a giant baby
decapitated it and it's now haunting
them as a ghost i'm pretty sure this
show is just
actively trying to disturb me at this
point check it out we can see stacy's
house from here peeping toms
well i'm gonna tell mom and when she
sees what you are doing you are going
down
you think candice i'm pretty sure if
your mom finds out her son built a
functioning city-wide roller coaster in
a single afternoon she'd more likely be
proud and then try to figure out how
they'll spend that first million phineas
will receive after selling his
blueprints
that's dorkist also pretty sure that
should be dunk two dorks candace let's
pay a little more attention to specifics
with your imaginary musical scenarios
i know this is just a model in clearly a
setup but that's a lame roller coaster
that also appears to be incomplete
love is in the details friends we tear
because we care also why does officer
candace even need a flashlight when
there's obviously overhead lighting
also also unholstered finger guns here
candace insinuates that she would like
to see her brothers compacted in a
garbage truck and this show is a lot
darker than you remember
see no discernible music source phineas
would be musically gifted at tv since
they're still wearing their candy in the
kisses 60s girl group outfits
as we go back to reality so i'm not sure
what to even believe anymore
i see so the extent of the thought in
these first three songs was basically
having characters repeat their own
catchphrases over and over but with
music
got it i'm excitedly looking forward to
other shows doing this seeing bart do
the ballad of eating my shorts or
seinfeld symphony of the yadayada
i feel like there's a story where
isabella lost all of her hair but
thankfully her mother was an expert at
making curtains for puppet shows
my whole world is the screen no it's not
we've seen you in the real world many
times your hyperbolic musical musings
are built on a house of lies
carl oh sorry sir good thing both the
light switch
and carl have mics on so we can clearly
understand this joke pizza nolan movie i
guess
setting aside where candace is even
getting these outfits or why she's
wearing a spacesuit when it was her
brothers that went to the moon i'm just
impressed that the actress who plays
candace was able to run all the way
around the aisle and do a complete
outfit change in time to get back to the
other side and maintain the rhythm of
the song
that's some top-notch cardio
now we're getting into clip show
territory maybe it's a clever variation
but clip show territory nonetheless
you can be a sequel slash reboot or
eclipse show but you can't be both pnf
space and time would converge upon
themselves so tightly bill and ted face
the music
look like foreplay why are all these
stepford moms exactly alike while their
children
are all different the animators gave up
didn't they
i mean technically the second roller
coaster isn't finished yet so i'm pretty
sure this just makes candace a big fat
liar
sorry that's the rules aren't you a
little young to build a roller coaster
funny scene and all but phineas just
told ferb he was off to buy snakes so at
the very least phineas should be
carrying a bag of snakes with him
i can't wait to see all the other body
part buttons wait sorry i think we did
that one last time
i'll make it completely fresh for this
episode i can't wait to see
all the other body part buttons and test
them on ordinary people
like timothy hutton's the hair button
the shoulder button the button for the
knee the nose button the tongue button
the one on your belly
am i musical incorrectly i know you're
probably
expecting some tragic backstory to
explain why i want to reverse the
rotation of the earth superman already
showed us that reversing the rotation of
the earth is a way to reverse time
and a way to injure a movie that was 2
hours and 15 minutes of perfection up to
that point
there may be many things you find
disturbing about this song but for me
those face balloons in the background
beat them all i'm sorry maybe you didn't
hear what i said
face balloons hanging your poster with a
single screw
also i can't figure out if getting the
roller coaster up already is the most
unbelievable part or that they were able
to get these posters made in the same
amount of time
do you think we'll get in free with this
poster we didn't last time good thing
you all just happened to be here again
right when ferb just happened to decide
to put it up again and candace just
happened to be trying to prove something
to her mom again i mean the convenience
was pretty high the first time around
but conveniencing in the exact same
convenient way again
is ultra conveniently convenient if
anyone's gonna ride this thing it's
gonna be me
not one of you lousy extras but multiple
people can ride a roller coaster at one
time
if you're gonna break the fourth wall
pnf make it matter oh
candace you have done this before will
you ever learn to
take the evidence with you when you have
the chance
[Music]
what the bird doesn't get a song lame
look we sinned all that they survived
this is and that this works is the first
time around so for efficiency's sake
just go watch that video again and we'll
just add a few sins here for the generic
they survive this workingness that's
happening here
why all of the sudden did this
rollercoaster turn into a well-designed
steel corkscrew and just a few seconds
ago it was held together with random
pieces of wood particleboard duct tape
and dumb luck
phoenix and ferb are clearly defying the
remain seated with hands arms feet and
electric guitars that aren't plugged
into anything but still amplified
somehow
inside the vehicle at all times sign i
love how they pretend to care about how
these tracks are held up here
and here but once they got to the tower
loops they're just like okay this part
floats
okay what did you think a million
dollars was just going to fall out of
the sky
it doesn't work that way how does it
work then
okay that's funny is it just me or is
this a serious deja vu moment
do you mean this exact thing happening
in the pilot or the self-referential
awareness of repeating things resulting
in a character breaking the fourth wall
and knowing they are on a tv show cause
both are happening with shocking
frequency oh look a couple future
candaces are checking in on this moment
that would be a nice wink to the quantum
boogaloo time travel episode except in
that episode they say they're going back
to the first day of summer which would
have been the first roller coaster
invention and not this musical retread
my point is if you're going to hide
easter eggs make sure they haven't gone
bad because we'll sniff that stuff right
out i don't remember this in the
blueprint
action park the meep cameo would be more
impressive with an english mustache and
if you're wondering how i know about
meep but didn't know about balloony
earlier maybe i did but i'm still afraid
of face balloons now go edit your tv
sins doesn't know balloony comment to
say tv sins i will never doubt you again
and let's move on oh sure the nose of
the coaster has re-entry flames but none
of their faces do
i demand melting faces sorry guys this
job does things to you
but still look those kids faces should
definitely have melted by now
roll neon lighter merchants actually in
this case credits
literally roll credits
stop that stop that you're not going
into a song while i'm here despite
popular belief we love movies and we
love talking about them check out the
syncast podcast where i'm joined by my
fellow cinema sins creators to talk
about movies rankings rants and more
available here on youtube or search for
scenecast for every stream podcast
what is this that when we were growing
up like we would try to die for fun
i feel my job is to make sure this
program is
morally upright and cultural and awesome
by the way glenn miller played
songs that made the hit parade
and you're not crazy because you really
think you're gonna convince me i'm crazy
huh
[Music]
coming on to our stage right now give it
up for
chastity is it just me or is this a
serious deja vu moment deja vu is
usually a glitch in the matrix
it happens when they change something